and the government released its gross
domestic product report for the second
quarter this morning it showed the US
economy grew 4.1 percent from April
through June that's the best showing
since 2014 the US economy has been
growing for nine years making this the
second longest period of growth on
record CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger is with us good morning Jill
put these numbers in context for us well
it was really an amazing quarter as you
said nearly the best in four years but
if we look even a longer term go back to
the year 2000 it's in the top 10 of
annual growth quarters that we've seen
since that entire time horizon
what really powered this was a
combination of effects number one we
know that those tax cuts really started
to boost business spending consumers
stepped up at a very good pace in the
second quarter the government spent
money and there's this really weird one
time and impact of the tariffs a lot of
foreign buyers wanted to buy US goods
before tariffs went into effect so we
saw a huge surge in soybean experts
before the prices started to change
rushing even before the door closes so
what does this mean on a longer-term
basis about the health of the economy
and more important for regular folks
well I think the health of the economy
is good but often we'll do these
segments and I'll hear from people and
they'll say gosh I don't feel like I'm
part of that and what's going on so it
is undeniable that growth was really
strong in the second quarter it has
picked up in 2018 but there is still a
lot of Americans who are struggling we
just have not been rising enough to
offset the impact of first the recession
and certainly now prices starting to
rise so we hope wages will pick up by
the end of the year still a very good
quarter all right Thank You Jill always
good to have you at the table